i'm not making much money at all
and i'm in fact losing some i'm losing
pretty good bunch of airplanes and
different different reasons i'm not i'm
not doing very well during those few
years
okay but early 80s it was kind of a dry
time
mexico had got so hot and i'd been shot
up down there and tortured in a mexican
prison until i didn't want to go to
mexico anymore
well you you when did this happen you
were you were tortured in a mexican
prison i
was tortured almost to death would you
let me tell you about that
i'd like to tell i'd like you to tell me
about that yeah please roger
oh and this is this before or after
the medellin cartel was formed oh before
before this is why i didn't go back to
mexico anymore the
couple of episodes happened down there
that i that was not healthy
okay uh yeah please tell me about that
anyhow i was arrested in mexico
and uh my seven
agents and i won't get into that long
story where i not went ahead and got
away from all of them with the bullets
flying
and got away but i had a pilot coming
down
an older gentleman and he landed at
hermessell
at the international airport he was
supposed to land five miles beyond
a cattle ranch a feedlot and he just
i don't know why he did it but anyhow he
had my phony name and my room number
in his pocket and he had five thousand
dollars in the
federal he tried to take it from him and
he wrestled with him no no roger said
give it to so-and-so
see anyhow they arrested me and put me
in prison down in mazatlan
and they've done a number on him up in
hermessy and he told
so they want me to confess
so i just can't believe it i haven't
done anything i'm just in a swimming
pool and i'm in my
swimming shorts and i get handcuffed in
the pool when the guy shakes hands with
me
where like a house or something they're
in a real nice hotel real estate
so they take me to the prison and i sit
there and i sit there and i mean it was
miserable and it was so hot
and uh after about three days in that
little in that cell which is where all
the
drug addicts and drunks are thrown they
take me back there to the torture
chamber and they decide i'm going to
tell
and they hold my head under a gaseous
water until i can't stand it any longer
and then you just fight like crazy to
come up and it burns your
daylight held your head underneath
underwater yeah it's like a tub and it's
got some kind of
uh bubbly it's if you inhale it it will
make you
nearly explode your head okay it goes up
your nose any after one time of that you
it take for them to hold you down wow so
anyhow i had that and then
i was beaten all over until i was just
yellow and black what were they asking
you or were they trying to get anything
out are they
they just sign the papers and they'll
all be over signing it'll be over
they'll grab your hair and shove it up
sign the papers
so what were the papers for just to
confess that you were
marijuana smuggler and you're going to
get six years in prison okay i thought
well if you don't sign it i knew
they can keep you two years for nothing
right but
so they give the um
they they uh the room was about five
foot square and
14 feet high and it was hot there's a
little spot on the door about that big
and they brought a man in he's a black
man and he was wrapped in uh
he was frozen and he was wrapped in
newspaper about inch strips around just
like you'd wrap something
like a mummy and you're completely
frozen and they stuck the ice hook in
his rib
he must have been used over and over
again and they hung him on the wall
and as he thawed out his eyes the water
run down his face and it looked like he
was crying
and then of course the water the
formaldehyde ran out of his orifices
other ones too
the old paper come running off of him
and later on you could see his liver
where it's pulled apart
and he'd open the door you next son of a
[ __ ] you next
and so anyway
that didn't scare me so bad i butchered
large animals all my life but i didn't
the smell was awful with that
formaldehyde puddling on the floor
and the floor didn't bother you that
much well as far as
liver and a dead man it just that that
didn't scare me
okay all right it's i don't like it but
it was no more than if you had a
whatever yeah so i had to sleep that
floor was filthy and on the wall with
dried blood where they that was just one
of the room that they hurt people in
they killed you back there so i went to
sleep and i put my head down
at the bottom of that door to breathe
like that and i'm breathing fresh air
from that side but i'm getting a
formaldehyde
over close to me and i went to sleep
and i had i know where walt disney got
some of his cartoons from i had pink
flying for pigs and horses and
all kind of colorful animals flying
around in my
in that state of mind from from
breathing the formaldehyde i was hiding
something and so then when i woke up and
i saw that dead man hanging there
it took a minute to figure out which was
a nightmare and which was real
i had to kind of pinch myself to see
which
where the reality was right and
then they took me out and they bent me
over naked
and buttered my rum bum and
packed it full of hot chili ground chili
and i'm talking about screaming and
talking ugly i did some of it
and i looked at their faces if i can
find you i will kill you if i can get
out of here
oh my god and then uh
so just one day uh uh
after after that they put me back in
general population for a few days
and you didn't sign anything obviously i
didn't saw of course i didn't sign it i
would have died for it signed up six
years for nothing that's right
uh so back there i got a word out
and tamari and some other people and
then one morning they just come said
come come
quick and they took me out the back door
of the prison
and they put me in a pickup truck brand
new and it had a horse's head on the
door and they sped through the streets
of mazatlan
and they went to a bank and
i went into banker spoke english and he
said listen joaquin that's where i got
shot down that morning and that's a load
i went back after
uh has given roberto the fif 17
000 that you paid for the loan and he
has paid it for the
to get you out of this prison are you
satisfied with that don't ask man
so i went to the hotel where mari was
and we got on the 747 and i didn't
believe i was out of there
i looked terrible how many days were you
there about three months
three months and so i got out of that
place and uh
when the when the uh tires of that 720
said it was a brand new plane
i just couldn't believe they're going
not going to come get me again i was
in the wheels went up to pump next stop
log angles i was like
wow that was on the fourth of july 1970
after that i
i gotta say man i would have been like
ready to call it quits
i didn't i didn't want to go back to
mexico anymore that's one reason i kind
of quit
i had another encounter that was bad
there too so uh
after after several of those encounters
okay i uh i decided to go to columbia
columbia they don't they don't treat you
as bad if you go to prison there they're
more professional more professional you
didn't go to prison you just had
professional people
loading you had good gasoline and okay
we had a better operation goal
they were these other people were
peasants that
you know someone maybe couldn't even
read and write it had something going
oh man
you